for 50 000 years or so
man hasn't the species has not been
evolving
in the soma type some type is relatively
steady
what is evolving is culture and what
culture
is really is language uh
culture is merely the uh epiphenomenal
accompaniment
of language so it is the evolution of
language that is
changing and all our ontological
all our religious ontologies in the
western tradition the insistence on the
coming of the word into the world
rel the word becoming flesh in a sense
man is the word become flesh
and what all this leads to i'm not sure
i often like to think that our map of
the world is so wrong
that where we have centered physics
we should actually place literature as
the the central metaphor that we want to
work
out from because i think literature
occupies the same relationship to life
that life occupies to death
and i don't think very many people have
thought of it in this
well in the sense that a book
is a is life with one dimension
pulled out of it and life
is uh is something which
lacks a dimension which death will give
it
i imagine death to be a kind of release
into the imagination
in the sense that for uh
characters in a book what we experience
is an unimaginable dimension of freedom
and this is why people like james joyce
though arcane and difficult to pierce
seem to me
central to understanding this because
they're saying something
about the relationship of books reality
and death that this is a cycle
of expansion and understanding that is
happening through language at one time
there were no books
without trying to
solve the problem once and forever let's
just say
man has a very strong
gnostic bent and
you know gnosticism dualism the idea
that you don't belong where you
are you belong somewhere else that this
is not your world that you're a stranger
in it is uh symptomatic in modern
parlance of what's called
alienation you're supposed to like where
you are
you're supposed to see yourself as part
of
the seamless fabric of being and that
sort of thing
however the people who take that
position
that that alienation is symptomatic of
neurosis
don't realize that the cultural momentum
of the last
500 years has made the gnostic myth the
reality
in other words we have become a
menace not only to ourselves but to the
planet
and the only way that both parties
can save themselves
is by a separation and this
on one level is the greatest
uh crisis that biology has
faced since animals left the ocean for
the land
on another level it appears inevitable
in the present social context that we
are going to go to space
but we are the birth pangs
of doing this are very destructive
for instance and i'm sure you've heard
me say this
that civilization is a 10 000 year dash
to space with the potential to destroy
yourselves
we history is the departure of a species
for the stars but it takes 10 to 15
000 years a moment of biological and
geological time
but in that 10 to 15 000 year period if
you happen to be unlucky enough to be
born
somewhere in there it's going to look
like it's all up for grabs we are
creatures of information
and the imagination the monkey
we are already beginning to transform
and
shed we don't look like the other
monkeys
and we look less like them all the time
we are humanness
may not even be a monk equality
it may be something that was synergized
in the monkeys but that is taking
that has an inner life of its own in
other words
we since the early 1950s have had a
notion of the structure of dna
and this sort of thing well it's
perfectly obvious that within a century
of the discovery of dna any species
which makes that discovery
takes possession of its own form
and we are going to do that in the next
50 years we are going to design
the we are going to design the kind of
people that we want to be
and if we don't want to be people we
will design
that out of the picture i think of
the picture that the mushroom
has of the human species is much more
like
a coral reef in other words it sees our
artifactry
as contiguous with our flesh
we make a distinction but what it sees
is an animal which takes in raw material
and excretes it in ideological molds
that's what we do we turn ideas into
facts on all levels and this cannot go
on
any longer on the surface of the planet
with the levels of energy and control
that we have brought to bear
because we are now in a position to
destroy the whole earth
or to sculpt to turn it into a
disneyland which is a kind of destroying
of the earth
so we have become a toxic force in
planetary biology
i don't know it's it's a great uh
it's a great challenge to us to fulfill
the things that we can imagine we are
capable of
our imagination is really the sale of
the soul
and the question is you know where will
that sale take us
if we will but let it
you